i just want like everything to be
successful i don't like
no mediocre cardi b is opening up about
her finances
in an interview with xxl magazine the
wap rapper got
real about her enormous success as well
as some of the hard lessons she's
learned as an entrepreneur
oh yes honey cardi said quote i feel
like i've been on deals before that like
yeah i got paid but i feel like i
deserved more
and as her empire continues to expand
cardi isn't letting
anyone deny what she brings to the table
in 2021
she added and i make sure this year that
i get everything i deserve
not just on music deals but on
everything
there's some big big things on the way
big bangs and cardi revealed it's helped
that husband offset wants to see her win
and when talking business he will tell
her things like you deserve this
i gotta see it to believe it i gotta see
it to believe it i gotta see the numbers
i like to see the numbers i like to see
the facts
cardi also spoke out against companies
that take advantage of people of color
and said that she's seen artists get
ripped off especially when compared to
white social media influencers
cardi said sometimes you do see that
race
really matters i used to think i was
weird i used to think like
i was different from everybody and i
wasn't and when it comes to labels
cardi revealed she doesn't mind being
categorized as a quote
female rapper put simply she said i'd
rather be the first
billionaire female than just oh she's a
billionaire
when cardi spoke with e.t in 2019 she
opened up about the struggles that can
follow success
as your career gets bigger and bigger
how are you feeling about stardom is it
everything that you
thought it was going to be is it harder
better it's
definitely harder like the more money
the more problems the more people
um that things they know you
and their opinions it just gets harder
people don't understand
some people don't understand the the
struggle some people don't understand
the work that i put in so they will just
always try to think that it came
easy for me and it's just like you know
it's something that i never thought it
would be like i totally understand the
meltdowns that these artists be having
why they be shaving their heads why they
go through what they go through because
this is crazy